all right i see that attendee list
growing but we're going to go ahead and
get started as others continue to join
so thank you so much for joining us for
the decolonization of development
economics early voices from the global
south discussion
this session opens a virtual symposium
devoted to race ethnicity gender and
economic justice around the world hosted
by yale's economic growth center and
inclusion economic cl
i'm catherine chaney i'm a reporter for
devx focused on technology and
innovation in global development i also
moderate the yale development dialogues
which some of you may have seen and i'm
really thrilled to be moderating this
discussion
so we'll be discussing how a pioneering
group of thinkers from low and middle
income countries inform the foundation
of the field of development economics
we're joined by panelists who will tell
us a little bit more about these
economists and the legacy that they left
on the field particularly when it comes
to the recognition of this interplay
between race ethnicity gender economic
inequality and global development
we'll have a conversation about how
particularly in this time of extreme and
growing inequality these perspectives
from history can inform the future of
development economics
before i introduce all of our panelists
i'd like to introduce rohini pandey
henry j heinz ii professor of economics
and director of the economic growth
center at yale and gerald d jaynes a
whitney griswold professor of economics
and african american studies and urban
studies at yale they're going to provide
a bit more context on this conversation
we're having today and how it connects
to the larger symposium so
as i often say at the beginning of these
kinds of conversations why this topic
why now we'll start with rohini
thank you catherine and thank you uh
everyone for joining it's um
i'm very happy to uh to welcome all of
you on behalf of the economic growth
center
and it's the 60th anniversary of the
economic growth center and we're
delighted to be able to host
this panel
so in the early 1950s as the cold war
began to gain steam and colonization was
ending ford foundation was increasingly
concerned with the idea that poverty
causes conflict
they asked lloyd reynold who was then
the economics department chair at yale
to travel to africa to study the
economic aspect of this decolonization
his daughter
called this trip a turning point in her
father's life because it inspired him to
change the focus of his work from labor
to development economics
interestingly his first development
economics research was on wages and
conductivity in puerto rican factories
and he interviewed over a thousand
workers in 85 factories and the most
striking fact of the paper he wrote was
to note to say that worker and foreign
behavior was remarkably similar to what
he had seen in more industrialized
nations and he directly challenged myths
that low-income countries would be would
look very different
after he came back he went to the ford
foundation for a year where he met simon
kuznets simon kuznets was at that point
john hopkins he was later a nobel
laureate and he often talked about the
idea that we needed a center that would
focus on the comparative study of
national economies
at that time there was very little
information about these newly uh
decolonizing economies and so kuznets
and reynolds
a seminar at the national bureau of
economic research in 1958 which then
became the basis of a proposal to the
fort foundation for economic growth
center
so in december 1960 the un general
assembly famously passed the 1514 u.n
resolution which was a declaration
granting independence of colonial
countries to people and very soon after
that in 1961 the economic growth centre
was founded with a 10-year foundation
grant
then went on to become an endowed sen
adult center later on but when it
started the la the largest organized
program it had was field study of recent
economic growth in selected countries
now
the idea that lloyd reynolds as the
chair put forward was that he would hire
assistant professors and in one of the
early reports that described the
production cycle
each of these
men would spend six to nine months in
new haven
learning language skills and analytical
skills they would spend up to two years
in the country chosen and then on return
they would combine teaching with working
material it was certainly an extremely
important way for the economics
department to grow 25 assistant
professors at yale were hired under this
program
and many of them went on to
be to be some of the first generation of
development economists in u.s uh
universities
so today when i look at the history of
those early years of egc which are very
well documented through the full
foundation archives you know some
aspects have certainly not dated well i
think there were a lot of young white
men who were being sent to the colonies
to study them but i think in other ways
it did identify a set of issues that
perhaps development economics lost a bit
of focus on along the way when it became
very technocratic which were issues of
thinking of
inequality asking questions of what
exactly do do people in these countries
both scholars policymakers and others
imagine as their focus
and then i think one reason why i'm
really excited to be doing this
conference with jerry
is that the early focus was very much
that is a continuum of issues that range
from the us to lower income countries
when we think of issues of inequality
when we think of issues of
how do we have process of economic
growth to work for all so i hope very
much that this panel can set stage by
reminding us again of what were the
discussions in those early days and with
that let me hand it over to jerry
thanks rohini
well thank you rohini
and welcome also to everyone
what i'd like to do is just take a few
minutes to
um
talk about what it is at least that i
think of when i when i think of the
phrase decolonization of development uh
and by that i simply i simply mean the
right of nations to self-determination
now i write that's of course only partly
one at this point but if we consider it
and what it means for
those peoples who are involved i think
it floats throughout as an underlying
thesis of the entire symposium that
we'll be doing
so to begin with when the growth center
opened during 1961
let's keep in mind over 80 percent of
the earth's people lived on less than a
dollar a day
women especially were engulfed in
exploitation whether they were in a
wealthy or poor country and gross
literacy illiteracy reigned globally
the cold war dominated
economic policy making worldwide
and colonial powers who were heirs to a
world economy born during a global slave
trade were reluctantly relinquishing at
least their formal control over people
of color across the globe
beneficiaries of the exploitation were
living in deep denial
my formal introduction to all this
occurred
rather coincidentally at that same time
that the growth center was opening up
when gene soderstrom the white daughter
of a republican family told my otherwise
all white ninth grade social studies
class that we were about to study for
the spring contemporary independence
movements
and so i began to learn a lot more about
names like gandhi and nehru fidel castro
guevara
patrice lumumba and kwame nkrumah
all leaders balancing tight ropes
between cold war powers who were vying
to control developing countries
resources and consumers
now suspicious of capitalist colonizers
the newly formed nations
tried alternative paths of economic
development
the marginalized economist must
recognize that the demand for
self-determination
without
abandoning rigorous thinking
she needs methodologies and models that
elucidate the problems of the world but
also speak to her marginalized identity
in a profession that has unfortunately
been steeped in ways of thinking that
often underpin her marginalization
most adopt a premise of post-colonial
studies
colonial rulers are unreliable narrators
of their subjects conditions
two economists
whose careers exemplified this tension
who i met along my way in the early days
at yale at the economic growth center
were carlos diaz alejandro
an egc colleague of eight years and sir
w arthur lewis with whom i co-taught
during a year he visited the economic
growth center
i think it was 1979
born respectively in cuba and st lucia
their caribbean origins
where slave trading and its aftermath
blended people of asia africa
europe and new world natives creating
colonized peoples
who shared my status as a member of the
world's marginalized
population
carlos the cuban refugee who loved cuba
for what it might become
and not its past shattered stereotypes
of the cuban immigrant blindly opposed
to socialism real or imagined
he supported renewing u.s cuban
relations even during the cold war
he opposed colonial
colonialist power relations throughout
latin america
and his refusal to back u.s imperialist
intrusion into nicaragua during the
1980s
are a stark revelation of the open
tension that exists in the perspective
of a well-trained economist
familiar with both the growth potential
of markets
and the human rights of peoples
determined to find their own voices
w arthur lewis
his celebrated paper
economic development with unlimited
supplies of labor
for which he won a nobel prize becoming
the first and only
person of african descent to do so
also exemplifies what i'm calling this
post-colonial turn
his ideas of surplus labor disguised
unemployment
postulation of zero marginal product
leading to contemporary models of family
utility maximization and intra family
equity
were all anathema to the neoclassical
model his contemporaries were
formulating
isolate the essence of his british style
economic training
which
attempts to reconcile his rational
modeling with his gut-wrenching life
experiences in the caribbean and
elsewhere
and we
see
the beginnings of a atmosphere about
which his ideas might have been formed
if we throw in his experience in britain
where he was engaged in
near daily ferocious debates over
politics and economic development with
the likes of clr james of jamaica and
eric williams of trinidad
tobiago
who who along with other caribbean
thinkers like franz fanon of martinique
and amy cezaire also martinate whose
discourse on colonialism
and his notebook of a return to my
native land along with w.e.b du bois's
drivings of the negro people might
arguably be
uh called the foundations of the field
of post-colonial studies when we see all
this and we think about that training
and that experiential existence as a
member of marginalized people of the
world we can think that this is the
surroundings that began lewis's
framework
for discussing the reality of economic
development and policy making in a
multi-sector
complexity
thank you jerry and you're really
setting us up for success here in terms
of something i had asked all of our
panelists to think about which is
you know our audience members might have
different levels of familiarity with
some of the economists who are going to
come up
and i asked each of our panelists to
really tell us about these people as
people who were they um
what what impact did their ideas have
what challenges did they face what
legacy have they left um and that's a
great preview of uh arthur lewis and
we're going to hear a little bit more in
just a moment so with that i want to go
ahead and introduce three additional
panelists ravi konbur david engerman and
amna kyum
ravi khanver is a professor of economics
at cornell university he researches and
teaches in development economics public
economics and economic theory and some
of his research and writing has explored
arthur lewis who you'll hear about a bit
more in a moment
david angerman is lightner international
interdisciplinary professor in the
department of history at yale and and
the jackson institute for global affairs
at yale university
and amna kyum is a post-doctoral fellow
at the jackson institute for global
affairs also at yale
each of them have insights on how some
of these early founders of development
economics arthur lewis and others shaped
our understanding of development and i
want to note for our audience that i
certainly have a lot of questions for
our panelists but we want to make this
as useful for you as possible so please
go ahead and use the q a function on the
zoom webinar to ask your questions
throughout and i'll ask you to keep them
coming throughout not wait until the end
so we can make this more of a
conversation and get your perspectives
in from the get-go
ravi i'd love to start with you so um as
i mentioned
this was a preview that jerry provided
on arthur lewis i wonder if you can tell
us a little bit more about his work
challenges he faced including racism as
you've written about and and the legacy
that he's left on the field
well thank you thank you very much
indeed catherine and my thanks to uh
rohini and to jerry for the uh for the
invitation
i'll pick up uh from where jerry uh
started uh on arthur lewis just to say
arthur lewis was born in 1915
uh in in the west indies
and he he he died in 1991 and then
having won the nobel prize in 1979 so
that sort of locates him
in time
and as arthur said he was an absolutely
brilliant student as jerry said he's
absolutely brilliant student
won a scholarship to the london school
of economics
uh and in the 1930s he interacted with
this book a group of radical
young black radical students a lot of
them from the west indies by the way
including also paul robeson who who at
the time was at at oxford not uh not at
the lse uh and you know it was at melia
and it led to quite a radical stance on
his part uh in the 1930s and 1940s
i think what's interesting to explore is
how arthur lewis
over the years
uh uh became more mainstream so to speak
and moved a little bit more to the
center uh through his engagement uh with
actually the decolonization process and
and so on
uh and the he faced uh quite
considerable uh racism in in britain
uh one particular thing you know he he
was he was he was appointed to the
equivalent position of assistant
professor at the lsc uh the first black
man uh in history to have done so
but at the time of the appointment the
chair of the department
felt although the chair had the perfect
right to make the appointment felt he
had to write the board of governors at
the trustees in other words of the lse
because he said we're going to be
appointing a black man to this to this
position and this is at the lsc the
london school of economics which was
founded by the great fabian socialists
sydney and beatrice webb so if in that
if in that institution you have this
going on then you can imagine what was
going on institutionally and in the rest
and in the rest of the rest of society
so that's just one example of these
things that he that he faced uh and he
and he was he was quite uh radical in at
that time in his writings and so on
now quite interestingly uh uh he had a
big interaction with ghana uh and uh
jerry mentioned kame and kruma kwame and
kruma was again a very radical leader of
ghana who led ghana to independence and
ghana became independent in 1957
and in march and in october 1957 arthur
lewis arrived in ghana as the chief
economic adviser to the new government
uh
so and indeed the reason why he was
invited to do so because the radical
government
of the so-called convention people's
party which won the election which swept
the election
thought that he would be bringing very
radical perspectives uh support for
industrialization support for state this
and that etc etc
and in fact it didn't quite turn out
that way
uh because although uh arthur lewis was
no market fundamentalist he was no
whatever but he actually looked at the
situation on the ground
and he argued actually in an earlier
report which he'd written that in fact
ghana should focus more on the
agricultural sector not on the not on
industrialization
whereas what nkrumah was pushing for was
sort of rapid industrialization uh uh
big infrastructure projects and so on
and so forth and that led to tremendous
conflict between him and arthur lewis
and actually the interaction between
economics and politics is also laid out
very clearly in this in this thing in
one of the in one of the letters that
kwame nkrumah wrote to arthur lewis
after arthur had criticized him uh for
uh for uh for the for the for the
economic plan he said
uh the advice you have given me sound
though it may be is essentially from the
economic point of view
and i have told you on many occasions i
cannot always follow this advice as i'm
a politician and must gamble on the
future
and kumar very famously said i had said
seeking the political kingdom first
and this this sort of uh tension between
what arthur lewis considered to be
rational economic advice and the
political realities on the ground is a
feature of that interaction between uh
off of arthur lewis's work in work in
ghana
and he then went on actually later on uh
sorry i went on later on actually to
write a book called politics in west
africa
in which he talked about this uh this
conflict actually in my writings i've
sort of let me just conclude with this
catherine in my writings i've i've sort
of argued uh that perhaps that perhaps
and cruma had a point
uh
that in fact uh and puma had to balance
tremendous cleavages in
in ghana across different ethnic groups
across tribes and so on and so forth so
what may be what may have
seemed economically irrational
may have been the way that he kept he
kept the whole show on the road by
balancing the different interests and
and so on and this tension between
economic political realities in a
society with deep cleavages
and seemingly economically rational uh
rational uh uh uh policy prescriptions
is something is a theme that that i
think we should be we should be focusing
on uh as as we think about economic
policy analysis
so let me stop there catherine and i'll
come back whatever whatever uh later on
thank you no i just had a follow-up
question for you which perhaps i'll save
so that we can bring in some other
perspectives from history but i want to
come back to you on it um i just thought
it was really interesting that you
mentioned how arthur lewis
moved from the radical to the mainstream
and i wanted to better understand the
evolution of his thinking but maybe we
can return to that i also really
appreciate that point you concluded on
this tension between political realities
and
what may seem like economically rational
policy prescriptions so i hope in terms
of finding a narrative thread between
these different figures from history we
can understand how economic theory
bumped up against reality and how that
shaped um this evolution of their
thinking but thank you ravi that's
really helpful and we'll come back to
you with some of that um so david i know
you've done research on a number of
development economic development
economists who were at cambridge
university around the same time and
their legacy so can you tell us a little
bit more um maybe zoom in on a few
examples in terms of
who were these people and what legacy
have they left on the field
that's right thanks catherine and uh
thanks to our organizers i'm writing a
history of development economics that's
told through the lives and works of six
practitioners all six were born in the
early 1930s and british in britain's
south asian colonies they were too old
to be salman rushdie's midnight's
children
born in independence in 47-48 we might
call them instead midnight's teenagers
all six uh as you say catherine came uh
to cambridge uh at that point um
certainly thought of itself as the
premier department in the world and had
a pretty good case for doing so all six
went on to greatness at national uh
regional and global scales uh one of
them amartya sen won a nobel prize in
economics another manohan singh served a
decade as prime minister of india
a third jagdish bhagwati is a perennial
nobel contender
a fourth mabubulhak invented the now
ubiquitous human development index
actually with some help from a
marchessan and others who i'll talk
about uh in a second and two others
shape policy and public life in sri
lanka that's the lal jayawardena and in
bangladesh that's rayman who actually
worked as a essentially a freedom
fighter against um
for the independence of bangladesh in
1971.
all six of them at one point or another
worked at this exact nexus of policy and
economics that ravi uh just raised and
we would come back uh to that issue as
well uh all of them also face this this
important dilemma which is they uh at
cambridge they learned uh economics that
was based almost entirely on the
economic experience of the atlantic
world uh but they became interested in
economics initially uh in order to
understand the world in which they were
raised
what was then the third world war now
the global south
mabul hawk
has always had a ready answer
for how to handle this dilemma even in
his very first week at cambridge
he told the marchessan as the two of
them were reflecting on their very first
undergraduate lecture by the legendary
joan robinson huck said that cambridge
economic economists were asking all the
wrong questions
but instead of ignoring them huck told
amartya sen
we must learn the tools of modern
economics only then he said would we be
taken seriously and besides he continued
we can use those tools to pose and
answer the right questions and certainly
by the record they did ask the right
questions about the role of the state
and markets and development about how to
build a newly independent nation about
the relationship between poverty and
inequality and actually about the
ultimate purposes of development what is
development for
and the work i'm
doing i'm trying to write it as an
embedded history of development
economics it's embedded in time and
place specifically in the global cell
and this kind of cuts against the idea
of raised by many historians who see
development as a global north project
kind of acting on the global south
uh instead this shows how development
was fundamentally actually a global
south project from putting poverty
eradication at the center of the world
bank as
did
to the promotion of market reforms in
sri lanka and india as uh la jai warden
and manmohan singh did to the invention
of human development all of these have a
history that's fundamentally rooted in
the global cell
specifically this is an embedded
intellectual history one that sees the
fields ideas not as emerging fully
formed from the minds of economists but
instead coming in response to specific
practical problems kind of the friction
of
of theory and practice
all of these innovations and development
theory and practice came actually out of
efforts to solve problems theory doesn't
descend into the world but actually the
reverse efforts to solve practical
problems drove theoretical innovation
and finally this is a
history of development that's embedded
in networks of family and friends it
focuses on the uh intellectual milieu in
which the six scholars operated uh both
in their studies at cambridge um it
shows how the personal connections of
these scholars shape their work the
contacts they made with their teachers
and each other at cambridge and beyond
all six of these were part of
overlapping
kind of globe spanning networks that
shaped their agendas it also touches in
into being embedded in what these
economists learned at home shall we say
mohawk had two moments in the sun one in
pakistan
in 1969
and
when he announced that
even as a member of the pakistan
planning commission denounced policies
uh that he said countenance and even
contributed to inequality but really
relied on a decade's worth of work by uh
by his wife khadijah who had been
interested in by her own reports the
only one interested
in economic inequality uh among the
pakistani economy
huck's second moment in the sun
the in invention of the human
development index and human development
report in 1990 also built on networks
that he had known for network uh for
decades including a marxist said but
also on the decades worth of work by
khadija hux to explore new development
indicators
other such situations are apparent for
most of these scholars which i could
talk about if people are interested i
mean i think that it shows that these
embedded histories help uncover multiple
vectors of power and privilege
that deepen our understanding of how
development ideas take shape and how
they're applied at least that's what i'm
hoping to do with this forecast
thank you david and um yeah i think that
point is really interesting in terms of
the influence that uh mabu bulhak's wife
khadijah
had um on his work and yet it's hard to
find much information on that which is
part of the problem
and part of the value of the work that
you're doing so thank you so much and i
also um thought it was fascinating that
you mentioned you know the value of
these
perspectives these early development
economists bring to the field because
they want to understand the world in
which they were raised
what i hope we can get to in our
conversation and again perhaps a
narrative thread connecting these
different individuals is when you said
that some of these scholars were saying
the wrong questions were being asked
and they wanted to use these tools to
pose and answer the right questions i
want to better understand what were
those questions being asked and what
were those questions that they wanted
asked so hopefully we can return to that
in a moment but i want to bring uh amna
into this as well so i'm not i know that
your work has focused on akhtar hamid
khan in part who is very relevant to the
discussion we're having today so can you
tell us again more about the person uh
the path the legacy
thank you guys for the question and
thank you the organizers for bringing us
all together to have this uh
conversation um so as catherine
mentioned i'm working on um so my bigger
project is on intersections between
global biopolitics
and postcolonial development and one
aspect of it is thinking about how rural
development uh is imagined and practiced
in the 1960s um so two big points that
i'd like to make and i think this brings
um some of what we've been uh speaking
about together
um so
firstly i think um we've been talking
about the development of development
economics as opposed to a scientific
field of knowledge um but i'd also like
us to think about how it was shaped by
actors who we wouldn't traditionally beg
as economists or even academics for that
matter
and to get us thinking a little bit more
about the intersections between
developmental practice
and academic knowledge and how those
inform each other in different ways
and secondly i think what i also like is
to start thinking about the geography of
developmental foreign practice um and
david mentioned um these six economists
from south asia who converge at
cambridge um and have these exciting
trajectories across both the global
north and the global south but i'd also
like to insert geographies
from the global south as particular
sites um as crucial sites actually of
developmental thought which
put forward these models of
developmental practice
um so after hamilton just a very brief
biographical note um he's born in 1914
in abraham what is present-day india so
roughly condemn
boranes to arthur lewis um and he's not
trained as a social scientist but he's
rather
in today's um
you know speak would be a technocrat so
he worked for a little while for the
indian civil service under british
colonial rule um where in the early
1940s he's posted to bengal and in 1943
he
um dramatically resigned from the indian
civil service um as a sign of protests
against british colonial policies during
the famine of 1943. um and then for the
next few years he works
as a school principal in uh kamala in
what is present-day bangladesh
and then in 1958 he is appointed as a
director for the newly formed pakistan
academy of rural development in kamala
for president bangladesh but what was
then um east pakistan um and what he
developed here is well today known as
sort of like the formula model of
development and i'll speak very briefly
about the model because there are many
aspects to it um but it was based on
cooperative formation of village
cooperatives and participatory decision
making in which villagers would come
together
and decide on how to save and invest for
agricultural development um there was
also a focus on labor-intensive public
works um in which again the corporate
members would work together on projects
such as irrigation rural work drainage
etc
and a lot of these while they were
drawing on older forms of you know
thinking about cooperative models um
what distinguished formula in the 1960s
um were two primary things um firstly
was after hamilton's insistence on
participatory um and bottom-up
decision-making um to mobilizing the
community and its resources
um and this was different from sort of
earlier forms of u.s led community
development um that were pioneered in
the 1950s which sort of inserted
um outsiders to sort of teach
peasants how to
you know know how and how to practice uh
various forms of
agricultural practices
so while this was not always i mean we
could speak more about this it wasn't
always so seamless to practice in theory
um what was conceptualized
conceptualized was sort of two ways um
uh sharing of knowledge and a learning
process in which peasants were leading
their communities development
um and secondly um what made akhtar
muthan's thinking and the project of
kamela interesting was focused early on
from the early 1960s on women and the
household as what they call not as
objects of development but as active
agents of their own development um so
while we were seeing quite a lot of
focus in the 1960s on you know
development of spectacle and as robbie
uh mentioned in ghana there was a lot of
focus on you know industrialization so
you know the steel mill or the dam or
what have you and this was being
replicated in a lot of other
post-colonial countries as well
um what the model at carmela did was to
focus also on social norms
gender norms and reproductive practices
as
um
aspects of developmental thinking and
practice
um so through both sort of sociological
knowledge that was being produced at
kamala and um the projects that uh were
being pioneered um women were slowly
incorporated into developmental thinking
as key actors
um and not just actors through you know
whose reproduction must be control
although that was a big part of it and i
can speak more about it if anyone's
interested um but also as economic
agents who um
required technical and vocational uh
training
um so i think in this way formula also
provides an early glimpse into the ways
in which women were slowly being linked
into economic development
and thought in practice
and this would later forcefully i think
um inform academic knowledge in
development economics as a field and
what is um today known in the night uh
as the women in development approaches
in the
um 1970s which really came um to the
foreign global consciousness at that
point um with feminist economists such
as um davey jin and esther rose um
bowser they were forcefully theorizing
the links between economic productivity
development and gender but i think
focusing on
formula provides us an interesting
glimpse into not just how
you know academic theory affects
practice but how developmental practice
informs
the formation of development economics
in the field
thank you amna and um i i think your
question has inspired or sorry your your
remarks have inspired a great question
from our audience which is also a
question that i wanted to pose so you
talked a lot about um akhtar hamid
khan's impact on development including
this participatory decision making as
well as women as agents of development
staying on that theme of women for a
moment and specifically women in
development economics
one of our attendees asks could the
panelists shed light on the missing
mothers of development economics why do
we value less the work of joan robinson
krishna
bharadwaj and others relative to their
male counterparts so joan robinson came
up earlier um and you know i think
that's a great question and actually one
i was hoping to pose as well as a
follow-up uh ravi is is that something
you could tell us a little bit more
about
um sure i can say i can say a few few
words and uh you know david said that uh
the first first lecture that
amateur and mabu went to was joan
robinson's lecture
now joan robinson just took uh you know
she was born in 1903
and died in 1983.
so
i suppose in the 50s she would have been
in her 50s uh at the time
as an undergraduate in cambridge myself
she was a she was a presence
uh up there so to speak
but then as a young as a young faculty
member at cambridge as the equivalent of
assistant assistant professor at
cambridge uh again she was very much a
presence in the in the in the common
room in the faculty room
uh uh arguing and debating and so on now
joan robinson is actually known for two
at least two things in in economics one
is her contribution to economic theory
uh
in particular her analysis in the 1930s
of of monopoly
and uh uh
in fact she coined that she coined the
word monopsony which is where the buyer
of a product has power monopolies where
the seller of a product has power
monopolies are the buyer of a product
supply and the key product for where the
buyer may have monopoly have power
is of course labor
and we're seeing now with platforms and
so on and so forth the whole question of
monopsony uh the power that buyers have
of labor has come to the fore and it was
joan robinson who actually did the first
uh rigorous analysis of this back in the
night back in the 1930s
and there are other major contributions
she made to economic theory at the time
but relevant to this discussion she also
was very much engaged in in in
development questions and questions of
economic development
and two things i would i i would point
out in the 1970s
uh she became very very closely engaged
with a great indian economist he was he
wasn't at cambridge at the time uh david
uh he was an early generation he was he
was at the lse his name was k n raj k n
raj who who founded something called the
center for development studies in kerala
and was in fact part of developing the
so-called kerala model
uh
of of sort of social expenditures
uh uh attention to women's development
and so on and so forth and it was in
conjunction with the left-led
governments which dominated kerala for a
long time that if you feel like that was
the economic wing of the uh of that of
that whole development and joan robinson
had a very close relationship with k and
raj and she would visit uh the center
for development studies in trivendrum
on a very regular basis and engage with
policymakers and so on at the time so
that is one one area
the other area where i think uh
perhaps we can have more questions about
her is that she actually in the 1960s uh
engaged a lot with the developments in
in china
and with the cultural revolution and
north korea and so on
and the argument is that she
is that she was
is that she was too uncritical of the
developments that were going on in in in
the cul in the cultural in the cultural
revolution uh and uh
and also actually in north korea where
she gave glowing reports
of of developments in in north korea and
so there's been a debate and a
discussion on that in in the literature
uh harking back to
uh people in the 1930s who went to the
soviet union uh and and uh uh didn't see
uh below below the surface etc so you
know this is she's an absolute giant in
our in our in our in our field
uh and in my view for her contributions
to economics uh she should have won the
nobel prize uh plain and simple no no
question no question about it at all
so ravi as you mentioned she is a giant
in the field and um
you know this question from the audience
is why is her work perhaps
valued less than than the work of some
of her male counterparts um or perhaps
put another way why didn't she win the
nobel prize um
is this something perhaps rohini that
you want to comment on just in terms of
connecting this to some of the broader
themes of this symposium
happy to do so let me you know i
recently
wrote a piece on in fact the starter of
perhaps the cambridge uh school of
economics alfred marshall
and his extreme misogyny where he
was very opposed to women getting
degrees but also apparent seem to have
made very great use of his wife mary
billy marshall's great talents
as an economist she actually was a
co-author on a book with him on the
economics of industry which preceded
the famous principles of economics and
marshall very explicitly sought to keep
it
out of print once his book was published
but what i wanted to go with that is i
uh and as david in fact helped me
realize cambridge economists wrote very
detailed letters to each other uh notes
and they're all archived
i got a
email from
a young undergraduate at here who had
just finished last year she was one of
the top students of her year
saying um oh
i read something and i'll read it on a
second footnote 19 and this is something
i heard all the time from my
contemporaries that year
and so the the the court first of
marshall who described um
he put forward a set of arguments to the
cambridge senate and why we mentioned to
economics and one of them was he said
while he felt the questions asked by
women generally related lecture or book
work or else to practical problems such
as poor relief
men who have attended fewer lectures
read fewer books and perhaps likely to
obtain less marks and examinations are
more apt to ask questions showing mental
initiative and giving promise of
original work in the future
and she felt she you know she was always
here put into the category of the
industrious girl who came at the top of
her class but you know perhaps um was
not asking the smartest questions so to
link that back to what ravi said and why
the
many women didn't get credit i think
that's part of it so if you look through
the long arc of history as ravi said you
know uh joan robinson um
identified monopsony another person
whose name came up earlier was beatrice
webb she's the person who identified the
word collective bargaining in her book
on the theory of cooperatives it was
another book that
marshall actively told her not to write
because he told her she should focus on
women's problems not on collective
bargaining
and so
you know i think perhaps a very poignant
example of what happened to many of
these women and what continues on is
actually in a letter that
alfred marshall's wife mary perry
marshall
wrote to joan robinson in the 1930s when
her book on minoxidil came out
she was also the godmother to joan
robinson's daughter and she wrote thank
you for helping lift off the pro the
reproach cast on the economic woman
and i think you know we
this is something that we hear about
when it comes to race when it comes to
gender that the the canons of economics
were often written
um not just with the notion of someone
who doesn't really exist but also by
someone who had a very strong notion of
what work should be um should be
canonized and i think we are still
seeing the aftermath of that not just in
um you know women or
members economists from the global south
or
you know members of certain social
groups not getting the recognition they
should but i think even more broadly
than that um a narrowing of the
questions that we are asking in
developing economics
or economics more generally
absolutely thanks rahimi and we have
some great questions coming in it's
actually hard to choose which is a good
position to be in but keep them coming
uh i want to start with this question
which i thought was a great one um in
part because it's sort of looking ahead
and where do we go from here so this is
um an attendee saying a lot of ideas on
the decolonization of development
economics can be found in journals
produced in developing countries which
are not given prominence in the wider
world what can be done to harness these
ideas in the field of development
economics so let's say um
there are
economists right now who you know
50 years from now there will be a
webinar discussing their legacy
but perhaps much of their writing is not
getting the kind of attention that it
should globally
so what can be done to change that
thoughts on that question
and if not plenty others are rolling in
but go ahead robbie
well uh
so and let me let
let me
perhaps take a a somewhat more positive
uh forward-looking approach to this and
and say that you know if we go back to
the time of time of john robinson and so
on
uh
there really was only only cambridge if
you see what i mean in terms of
economics
very very very little in the way of
general communication and so on and so
forth and very restricted channels of
communication uh uh the economic
the economic journal was was a preserve
of a few people
and so on
and i think
what gives hope is that is that
situation has uh has changed because of
because of new technology and so on and
so forth so in fact that
some of these some of the perspectives
that one would one would have lost uh 60
70 years ago uh at least there's a
prospect that they will be that they'll
be uh
brought brought to the center stage
that's that's what i would that's what i
would uh
what i would say there's of course
always the always the issue in all
academic things and we have a bunch of
academics here in terms of uh
the rarification of certain of certain
journals and certain whatever but that
but that's but that's that that's the
academic uh academic frame yeah
thanks probably
i'm not do you want to jump in
yes um i think we're awesome to think
about the terms of engagement in which
um well just to use the catch-all phrase
um the global south is engaging um it's
being engaged with when it comes to
the field of economics and many other
academic fields where sort of well to
use the word shorthand local scholars
are seen as sort of research assistants
or information gatherers
and their their insights aren't seen as
being theoretically sound enough to
actually they're just there for giving
us sort of local knowledge and practice
and then it's someone who's sitting in
the global north um who will you know
fantastically come up with all these
great ideas um so i think maybe the
smaller things like co-authorship might
be a good way forward in recognizing
that it's
in sort of trying to make it a little
bit less hierarchical
in terms of how knowledge is being
produced
thanks on that i want to go to another
great question here um so someone asks
if one wants to decolonize development
then it cannot simply be
about a different kind of person
engaging in development so we've been
talking a lot about you know who these
thinkers
were and are and the importance of
diversity but this person as it must be
about using the tools institutional
power and methods to create
decolonization so the question is can
you distinguish the thinkers some of you
have brought up by clarifying which ones
sought development of the same old type
and which ones sought actual
decolonization so this gets a little bit
deeper into
the work the questions they were posing
the work they were doing
and to what extent um decolonization of
uh development not just the field of
development economics was um part of
their legacy so maybe maybe our
panelists want to jump in and shed a bit
more light on the people you talked
about in that sense
i thought it was a great question david
and it's a great question i feel like uh
for the six who i'm looking at they are
kind of all over the map on this one so
two of them win
uh remarkable accolades in
the academy of the global north by
guatem
uh i asked jen where he learned his
development economics and he said there
actually is no such thing as development
economics there's only economics uh and
so clearly
that his move is decolonizing in some
ways and not in others
one of the things
things that struck me is how
most of them uh most of the people who
i'm looking at got really deeply engaged
and devoted tremendous energies um to
working in uh to working in
international institutions and to
creating those institutions
so manmohan singh for instance who's
often thought of as a well rightly
thought of one of the um
the innovators in liberalizing the
indian economy in 1991 his prior job was
actually working for the socialist
leader of uh tanzania former leader of
tanzania julius naire in a project
called the south commission which was to
create a
think tank and a kind of nexus for
intellectual political life
by and for uh the global south uh a
number of of the people i'm looking at
worked at u.n agencies at one point or
another abubahak and khadijah together
created a series of
smaller more ephemeral organizations and
so
um they were very active i think and
devoted
extensive energy
to
institution building or to or working
within institutions to redirect them and
so i think that's one of the places
that we can see it it actually
requires perhaps leaving the academy or
at least in the case that i'm looking at
those who stuck in the academy
um
tended to be
doing conventional economics brilliantly
well
but not not rethinking all of the
premises uh
along the dimensions that we're talking
about here
very interesting point and partly
because perhaps
while remaining in the world of academia
those theories and concepts weren't
bumping up against realities that can
change your thinking
um other thoughts from our panelists in
response to this great question
otherwise we have others coming in but
ahmed did you want to say something on
this
yeah i'll just have um this is um
[ __ ] this is such a great question
and i think it requires a lot more
thought and explication but um what i
will say i think from um
and i think robbie also um mentioned
this is that a lot of the things that
they're looking at they're bumping up
against politics and in many instances
they're working with authoritarian
regimes so in my case after hamilton is
working with a youpan member as
david mentioned is also
an advisor in the in ukraine's regime um
so while they're having conflicts i
think they're more wedded to ideas of
postcolonial development
than decolonization
if um we were to think about
decolonization as a project of
self-determination maybe um someone like
rahman subhan who david looks at and who
is termed as a freedom fighter in the
liberation of bangladesh
i think maybe if we focus on him we can
think more about decolonization but i
think
some of the examples that we've given
there's definitely a link between
postcard and development
authoritarianism
and development economics um as a field
thanks um
as we have more questions coming in i
want to return to a couple things that
were said that i think might help build
some connections between these people
who've been brought up um so david that
actually starts with something you
mentioned um that some of the economists
you're focused on who were together at
cambridge during the same time talked
about how the wrong questions were being
asked and they wanted to um
change the nature of the conversation um
and pose and answer the right question
so can you expand in a little more
detail on what you mean by that
well i would just think for starters uh
one of the questions they all were
engaged with in different ways at
different times with inequality and here
you can look at this in two different
dimensions at a kind of domestic level
and at an international level and so
at the domestic level um we're talking
in a moment where uh inequality is seen
as a um perhaps unfortunate in some
cases but always necessary byproducts of
economic growth that would sort of solve
itself this is the famous kuznet curve
uh from simon kuznetsov rohini mentioned
was i think we find in in all of these
scholars of determination um even though
they had different uh prescriptions
shall we say a determination to address
uh questions of economic inequality uh
at the domestic level uh march marcia
sen i think in particular was focused on
the intersections especially in his
later work the intersection of economic
inequality and other um structures of
domestic inequality caste and gender
among them
at the second level of global economic
power
uh you know
it was
too easy for uh i think for economists
just to think of the world as made up of
um
uh
of nations with equal rights and
therefore perhaps equal entry points
into into the global economy whereas i
think people like john d schwagwati
manmohan singh lanzai warden that were
very focused on the nuts and bolts of
global economic inequality and worked um
bhagwati stayed mostly in academe but
the uh but thing in jail ward now worked
in the trenches to
at the imf actually at the u.n
conference for trade and development at
the south commission to try and um find
ways to address um to redress uh global
global economic inequality so those
those if i had one question that would
be it i'll be at the two part
yeah that's really helpful thank you
i want to bring in another question from
the audience actually two questions
related to arthur lewis and so perhaps
ravi or jerry want to jump in on this um
here are the two questions the first is
in relation to the tension between
economics and politics which has come up
a few times would you say that arthur
lewis covered aspects of this in his
book theory of economic growth that's
one question and then the other which
i'll throw in um when teaching i would
tell students that arthur lewis never
claimed the marginal product of labor
was zero he argued that in
non-capitalist sectors the marginal
product of a laborer could be zero if
compensated by greater effort by the
rest of the household unit
why was that insight so often
misunderstood so two questions directly
pointed at our um
arthur lewis experts here um and i
wonder if you can react to those and um
perhaps even shed a little bit more
light about arthur lewis and his legacy
in doing so
so ravi or jerry who wants to jump in
first
gary why don't you go first and i'll
then i'll follow up
you're muted
i would i was thinking that this was
more in your uh
ballet wick and you should go first
so please do
sure sure so the answer to the first
question actually i i don't think the
theory of economic growth was
was uh directed to that sort of question
of uh
the the intricate interaction between
politics and economics and and so on
uh
in fact in it it was uh it was lewis's
politics in west africa which sort of
took head-on head-on uh the question of
the of the econ and and and you know uh
and he was criticized for a lot of his
theorizing and that and and his analysis
and that but it was his attempt to make
sense of what he had seen and thing so
just another little quote from uh from a
from lewis
uh he he's talking about the development
plan in 1957 and 1958
and this was the exchange within kruman
which basically led to him resigning as
a as an advisor
he says
it is not easy to make good development
plan a make a good development plan for
100 million pounds
if the prime minister insists on
inserting 18 million pounds of his own
pet schemes of assault which neither
develop the country nor increase the
comfort of the people okay and that's a
very sort of technocratic economist type
uh perspective and of course and
chroma's response was the reason why the
whole show is on the road is because of
these 18 million pounds that i'm that
i'm using the in the uh in this way or
that way to keep to keep different
groups uh different groups happy and i
guess we as
certainly i as an economist haven't
haven't resolved that uh
that tension in my in my in my mind uh
so so that was that point and then the
second point is a much more technical
point so i'm not sure we should
necessarily get into it in in great
detail
but but it's but it's a great point and
actually going back to one of david's
six uh amateur sen actually had quite a
well-known paper
uh i believe he was in the general
political economy where he made
precisely this where he formalized this
point precisely
that actually uh
by
it might look to you as a as though this
unlimited supply of labor but actually
other members of the household are
adjusting their labor supply to keep
everything uh to keep everything as as
it as as it is
and guess who's actually adjusting the
labor supply when when a man leaves for
the uh uh
for the city
thank you ravi jerry anything you want
to add on that in terms of arthur lewis
well in terms of arthur lewis the one
thing i would say is that when he was
still in his uh 40s when he was uh
dealing with ghana and kwame nkrumah and
that
one of the characteristics of arthur
lewis that i discovered
was that even on important questions he
was willing at least later in his life
to change his mind
and i think that in some conversations i
had with him but even more importantly
in some formal lectures that i heard him
give uh he had meddled a bit from what
we might call a younger man in his 40s
sort of hardcore um technical this is
the economist and this and these
politics shouldn't be getting in the way
that kind of gets back to something ravi
was mentioning earlier in terms of the
evolution of his thinking um so i i
appreciate that we were able to go into
that in a little bit more depth um we
have some other great questions coming
in keep them coming now some of them are
um bringing up uh other
you know uh
early thinkers and development economics
who perhaps should also be part of this
conversation people from around the
world who contributed to the field um
and you know it i guess it points to the
importance of having a conversation like
this because we don't talk about these
individuals enough but um again just
trying to build a connection between
um
the people you all are focused on in
your research
this is one of the questions posed in in
the description of this webinar we
talked about um what set the stage for
this pioneering group of thinkers to
define development and i guess i will
ask that what um but i want to broaden
that a little bit so so what was the
context that allowed these thinkers to
make an impact on the field of
development and what were some of the
very real challenges that stood in the
way of them being able to make the
impact they could have so we've talked
about people who have been recognized
and received awards um for really
their contributions to the field but
also people who maybe didn't get the
recognition they should have and there
are many other names who aren't a part
of this webinar um
so i just wonder if any of you can talk
a little bit more about not just the
people but the context around them
including issues like racism sexism um
that you know what were they what were
the con conditions that set them up to
make a difference in the field and what
were some of the constraints that held
them back
i would say the the overriding um
precondition for it is the sort of
partial and uneven decolonization
um
which provided new forms of independence
uh especially
political uh
independence but also created um
reconstructed and reconfigured forms of
economic dependence it admitted people
born colonial subjects into the highest
citadel of western
learning in the 1950s especially in the
u.s excuse me in the united kingdom by
the 1960s increasingly in the united
states but also presented them with um
with kind of constraints uh and uneven
treatment i actually asked a number of
people who well of these six as well as
people who studied with them in the
1950s who were from south asia
and
almost to a person they deny that they
were treated any differently uh
in this time but you also get sort of a
counter narrative uh the widow of one of
them told me that um a march ascent and
lol jai wardner used to get confused all
the time like two people would confuse
one for the other even though they look
remarkably different uh i'm hard to send
a tall rail thin angular face and malja
award no
completely different and yet although um
there are some constantly uh confused
marchessan even told me that you know he
faced no discrimination he said either
for or against uh on the basis of his
south asian and south asian descent
um and so this unevenness i think is
really important it removes some
important in inequalities but left in
place or even reinforced other
uh
other kinds of uh kind of structure
there's a kind of more structural level
uh about uh forms of inequality so i i
would say that
the incompleteness of
of decolonization it was it was a long
process it was
an incredibly uneven process that um
that all these people are entering into
thanks david i'm not anything to add in
terms of um
and
the
constraints the context um both
opportunities and constraints um in
terms of his ability to really leave a
legacy
yeah so i actually think um david um
uneven decolonization is such a it's
such a good way to i think sort of think
about um the fear in the 50s and the 60s
that we're all i think sort of
collectively thinking about
um because while some hierarchies global
hierarchies
might have sort of been you know
reconceptualized new hierarchies were
created
even within the postcolonial nation
states so
um
i think so for um after hamilton i think
the code for geopolitical context is
extremely important
so while older forms of colonial
knowledge of about development um were
still in play but there were these new
forms of knowledge that were also being
created um so if we look at pakistan um
as an example i think we can't um
discount
uh sort of the co-creation of
academic knowledge in so many different
fields which was
you know at many times funded by as you
know even rohini mentioned in the
introduction um the force foundation and
particular
institutes such as the economic growth
center
um so
for afghanistan
his trajectory in the 1960s
was
he kept bumping up against a yukon's
authoritarian regime um and
um by sort of you know the
uh the traditional account is in 1971
he's uh sort of forced to flee kamilah
because it's a bangladesh war of
liberation but since the late 1960s you
can sort of see um that the state is a
yukon state is getting more um
insistent on uh putting forward more
status
programs of development in formula where
after hamilton then regularly has
disagreements and um sort of you know uh
threatens to resign he does resign for a
while then he's sort of reinstated um so
i think um
but then he's also backed by the ford
foundation advisors um so there's um all
these sort of call for geopolitical
tensions that um really um and the
alignment with an authoritarian regime
that really sort of
um
make this project really messy um and uh
once a sort of you know uh bangladesh
becomes independent
um then
um
whatever the legacy of formula was is
then reimagined in new ways um and it
does
um inform in the 1980s some of the
microgravity approaches
that are then pioneered in bangladesh
but um it's a story of where
politics
frequently rubs up against what the
development economics or practitioners
um have in mind
thank you i want to bring in another
question from the audience there are a
few questions around
early thinkers in development economics
from latin america um and that might not
necessarily be the um focus in terms of
our panelist expertise but just
questions around these early thinkers
from latin america perhaps being missing
from this discussion um and i think one
of the interesting points that came up
is how much of this work was originally
in spanish and sometimes lost in
translation to english which is perhaps
a challenge globally when we talk about
um great thinking um and development
economics happening from different
countries where english is not the
primary language so i just want to kind
of throw that out there
whether you want to talk about latin
america specifically or this challenge
of language and translation i just think
it's an important point to bring up any
reactions from our panelists
david
i i mean i agree with the thrust of the
uh critique that we're leaving out latin
america here i think in some parts this
is a kind of conceptual sense of of the
time that the the kind of the action if
you will was in
newly uh
newly independent nations and
so the caribbean uh gained independence
were you know uh where lewis and others
are from only in the in the 1960s
but
most of the rest of continental um
central and south america were uh were
already independent so if decolonization
is a name it sort of leaves out this i
think the work that raul prebish and
many others many many others did at the
economic commission for latin america is
is crucial what's striking to me and
i've often found this puzzling is how
little the south asian economists
connected with um with latin americans
either personally or engaging in
or even just in print that there's
there's this really strong disconnect in
the 50s and well into the 1960s
between these two
types of brilliant economists on both
sides
working independently on many of the
same questions um and i think one of the
questions we might ask is what's
responsible for that um
for that sort of
barrier or
missed connection if you will
yeah great point i'm glad you brought
that up uh ravi did you want to jump in
yeah just a quick a little uh nugget of
an a a just an observation uh
arthur lewis after he left ghana
uh went to uh
only came back once and that was in 1963
for a conference on
the seven year plan ghana seven year
plan
and here are some of the people who are
actually present
at the discussion of that of that seven
year plan
uh it's albert hirschmann
uh nicholas caldo
osvaldo's uncle
and ken raj the the people the person i
mentioned earlier as being very very
important so you know the point is i
think the the occasions for these people
to meet
and discuss
uh were few and far between i think
because this is the 1960s and so on and
travel and and so on and so forth and
the creation of these of these u.n
uh
the economic commission uh uh for asia
in the far east which was a cafe at the
time it's now escap economic and social
commission for asia and pacific and then
eclaq and latin america etc in some
sense
uh
uh i i suppose segmented the discourse
in that way and it's not difficult to
imagine that it was that it was
difficult uh for actual get-togethers uh
in in that time but here's one small
example where where
they all came to us as ghana's uh
ghana's plan
uh from latin america from uh india and
so on
very interesting and kind of echoing
your point earlier um when there was
this question about academic journals at
least a point of optimism is um sharing
sharing work across geographies is
easier today than it was at that time um
for for scholars to be able to come
together despite distance um i i want to
get to this great question from the
audience and it points to something that
i was hoping to get to in our
conversation one of the things i wanted
to really make sure we talk about is um
you know how are these figures that
we've talked about from history
continuing to inform development
research policy and practice and some of
you alluded to that in your remarks um
but here's a specific question
on their legacy today
so this comes from the audience um
thinking about the turn towards poverty
reduction and away from an earlier era
of focus on addressing global inequality
how did these economists relate to this
term what role did they play in it
uh i i can start with it i mean
at an institutional level um the world
bank then the and i suppose now probably
still the largest
single institution in the kind of
development landscape um
their turn toward poverty uh eradication
came primarily through the efforts of
mabul hak
who convinced the sort of dynamic new
world bank president uh perhaps doing
pendants for his uh
leading the vietnam war for the 1960s
robert mcnamara
to push
to sort of change the focus at an
institutional level
of the world
toward toward poverty reduction and i
then i also think that sticking with hog
for a second as a sort of the focus on
human development
helps us really understand the rise of
ngos on the one hand which were well
equipped to handle
um questions like uh health and
education which were at which were kind
of factored into human development
beyond just uh national income and so we
can see in this i wouldn't say that that
hawk uh kind of predicted or made this
happen but it was continent with a move
a move away from big national
institutions um toward international
ngos and and
even local regional and local ngos
taking on smaller scale um taking on
smaller scale projects rather than just
advising national governments and on on
their national plans
really interesting that's a world i i
cover closely and honestly i was not as
familiar with his influence on um the
development of really the whole ngo
sector so really interesting um other
thoughts in terms of more broadly how um
you know these figures that we focused
on today continue to affect um
development economics development policy
and this turn away from addressing
global inequality towards poverty
reduction which perhaps some might argue
may turn again toward addressing global
inequality given some of the issues
we're seeing
sherry do you want to jump in on that
yeah but just a
short small point
let's
let's not forget that uh reducing
poverty is
reducing global inequality and in fact
if one were thinking about what is the
quickest way in the short run that i
could
try to reduce
uh global inequality would be to try to
reduce
uh poverty one way of thinking about
this is that
um
because there was also an earlier
question about the uh
renus faye
it more formalization
of
lewis's model which ignored various
issues having to do with inequality and
things like that one way of thinking
about that is those
are models and ways of thinking that are
looking at
policies and issues and their long-run
effects
as opposed to thinking about the
short-term effects of of policies and
trying to do something in the short term
uh
and i think that this turn that's being
talked about uh towards poverty
reduction which is kind of getting at
the more micro a level of where
individual people are or individual
communities are are in fact thinking
about i want to do something about
poverty in the next five years or i want
to change global inequality even though
it may not be some huge change uh in the
short run so i think we have to put
those questions into some kind of
perspective
thanks jerry
other thoughts on this otherwise a
couple more questions really and ravi
yeah i suppose uh just uh
reacting a little bit to to jerry's
point uh
i suppose the concern might be that the
co what if the causality runs from
global inequality to
poverty in individual countries that's
because that's the nature of the thing
so in i suppose in an accounting sense
if i reduce
poverty in a country then almost by
definition global inequalities measured
will will reduce but does the global
inequality uh in some sense
uh
does it have the seeds of the the
structural processes which lead to uh
lead to poverty in this country so that
would be the
now you know arthur lewis again going
back to arthur lewis uh he he had some
his his sort of surplus labor theory
uh actually also helped him understand
he he says a global inequalities so he
has this phrase where he says uh when i
look at plantations he says there's been
tremendous technical progress in uh
efficiency gains uh in the production of
plantation crops uh over the last
hundred years or whatever
and yet he said i remember the phrase he
says plantation workers
are bare feet and and wear and wear rags
something like that he said my question
is why
it's because their wages are held down
by this
unlimited supply of labor that's coming
in from the countryside so all the gains
of technical progress are actually going
toward
to the owners of the plantation uh not
to the not to the workers uh it's when
that it's when that surplus labor ends
phase ends and wages start rising labor
markets tighten that's when you start
going to get the effect on good effects
on inequality of the of the technical
change and of course if one looks at
china's development just to bring it to
a contemporary airframe
that is one that would be one argument
as to why it is that inequality rose so
sharply in the chi in in in the chinese
context because there's this massive
supply of so so to speak surplus labor
coming in from rural areas essentially
holding wages lower than they otherwise
would have been
and
it was it was only really when the
so-called lewis turning point was
reached when when the labor market
started tightening in rural areas that
wages started rising in rural areas that
maybe some
positive effects on the reduction of
inequality started started coming
through so that if you like is a
translation of the louisiana perspective
from the 1950s to the uh
to the current chinese
discourse
some of us have been arguing that maybe
chinese inequality
at least is not
increasing at the rate that it that it
was
and one of the arguments is that uh
that the lowest turning point so to
speak has been has been reached
so i want to give enough time and space
to throw out one final question and um
given the complexity of what we're
discussing i want to make sure that each
of our speakers have really a couple
minutes for any final thoughts but first
i want to bring in what's a comment from
the audience that i think is highly
relevant um
the comment is
it would be great if the idea of
decolonization
transit transcended the list of early
greats and development economics to
encompass the new understandings of the
term that have emerged among people
working in the global south today um so
i think really that comment is
connecting this
conversation we're having in the opening
session talking about um these early
thinkers who influence the field of
development economics to the themes of
the symposium that will continue um
friday october 29th as well as friday
november 5th um so again the point is
you know how do we how do we talk not
only about these early greats and the
legacy they left but new understandings
of the term of the decolonization of
development economics um especially for
for people working in low and middle
income countries today
and and so to turn that into the form of
a question and really give each of you a
little bit
of time to connect
the people you talked about with the
themes of the symposium do you have any
final thoughts on the importance of
considering these early voices as we
gear up for the symposium focused on
race ethnicity gender economic justice
and global development um and we'll
start with
david ravi and amna and then i'd love to
close with rohini and jerry and help
connect this opening
session to the larger symposium david
can we start with you
i was afraid you were going to say that
catherine it's a really big question i'm
not exactly sure
um
uh exactly sure how to take it i mean i
do think
that the um
uh
the the question of inequality that was
so important to these figures um
really remains a central question
uh a question today uh and it was there
that was the right question that they
were asking i might actually add to it
something that's come up a little bit uh
i guess obliquely particularly in some
of ravi's comments um which is a kind of
i guess temporal inequality one of the
things that the scholars i'm writing
about were focused on
was consumption now versus consumption
later right and the idea would be that
what what some sacrifices now will will
provide
goods uh goods later joan robinson um
perhaps typically had a great uh
sentence about that when she visited sri
lanka in the late 1950s and saw this
robust well welfare state social welfare
state um that she said that sri lanka
was
eating the fruit before growing the tree
that it was spending rather than
saving for the short term and so i think
one of the issues that we see people
like mark hassen deal with in academic
and formal language and we see others
like mobile hack deal with in a kind of
more political vein is this other
dimension of inequality which is how do
you balance the the current against the
future
and it's plausible to think that with
our current interest in
um
in global inequalities certainly since
2008 um
even just an economic term that that
become central i would say that the this
group
for all of their insights the ones who
i'm looking at we're not necessarily the
right ones to look at the um
the interface of structures of economic
inequality with other structures of
inequality uh and
it's
two kind of vexing questions to answer
directly
um right now but i would say that when
you ask economists to talk about
inequality it's not a surprise that they
turn to economic inequality and so
perhaps the message is one of amnas
about bringing in um people working on
boundary you know
on the boundaries or economics and its
neighbors
as a way
to kind of continue this process moving
forward
thanks david amna can i bring you in
next
sure actually david that's a great segue
for me um so one of the things i was
going to say is that what the sort of
what was i mean um the commoner model
obviously has could be different
problems but the one thing um that it
was doing was that it was
interdisciplinary in nature right but it
wasn't just economists who were um
producing knowledge but it was also
anthropologists sociologists and
political scientists um who were there
and really like
they were living in formula they were
going out into the communities and
working with people and producing these
forms of knowledge so i think maybe um
sort of
focusing a little bit more and taking
more seriously local knowledges and
practices and then also broadening our
visions of what the political economy is
um to really bring reproductive
practices uh to bring the family um into
focus when we think about uh political
economy and it's not just about sort of
you know um rational economic agents um
i think that might be um sort of um ways
of you know something we should be
thinking about as we move forward with
economic justice and maybe one last
point
um when thinking again about a lot of
these development projects and where the
funding is coming from
um is to think more seriously about uh
sort of who what are the power
structures in place um
and who who you know who gets to benefit
the most uh from these forms of
expertise and funding and so just being
more attentive to funding flows as well
um great point thanks amna ravi
yeah so let me let me just say i mean i
agree with all the things that have been
that have been said on this thing and
just speaking as a as a as an economist
as an economist
uh you know economics has a lot of
strengths
uh but also a lot of weaknesses and i
say
perhaps the greatest weakness is that
economists don't know the weakness of
their weaknesses of their discipline
they
uh they focus a lot on the strengths and
there are a lot of strengths no question
about it
so i would say that for example that
that we we don't engage uh with history
we don't engage with actually the
history of our own discipline let alone
history more more more generally and
that's what we've been we've been seeing
that you know there are real insights to
be had by going back and seeing uh what
these greats
uh how they interacted with the world
and so on
and the second thing that we tend not to
do is to is to interact with other
disciplines uh uh too much
uh and i think what what the what this
discussion has uh what amna was saying
and others
uh really that that engagement
i think is not only not only not only
leads to a good policy making and so but
it also actually leads to good economics
and defined in its own in its own terms
so let me leave it at that
agreed and and that's part of why i'm so
grateful that rohini and jerry have
brought us together because it's
addressing some of those problems you
just articulated um this this discipline
not engaging with its own history enough
um and not engaging enough with other
disciplines and i think this this
opening session of the symposium and the
whole symposium will be really valuable
from that perspective so uh rohini jerry
you kind of kicked us off in terms of
why this conversation why now and would
love just any final reflections from the
two of you and maybe connecting this
conversation that we're having today to
the larger symposium jerry you want to
start
okay well just just very briefly i think
that
the last comments that were made um
kind of would take us back to i think
david was uh talking about someone among
his six who um
mentioned that at cambridge the
economist back in the um i guess the 40s
or 50s weren't asking the right q
questions well
at least they weren't asking all the
right questions and
that's where i think the rest of the
symposium is going to be trying to go
we've tried to bring together people who
are asking questions that uh
that are somewhat different from what
we're usually going to see um
in economics journals and part of the
reason for that i i would say
which connects to david's point and the
one that robbie just made as well as
amna is that
one gets rewards
in the economics profession
by
publishing in certain kinds of journals
and you publish in certain kinds of
generals by
on the basis of
methodological sophistication
so when you start asking why are
economists interfacing with economic
history
and with anthropologists or political
scientists more
that kind is already your answer you
that you're going to be posing questions
that are broader
than the ones that can just solely be
answered with the kinds of
methodological tools that are going to
get you published in in these journals
so we're kind of interested in uh asking
some of these broader questions and
asking how might we what methodological
means can we use to approach those
questions so i hope that uh
the people who were here with us today
can continue with us to uh get some some
of those answers
thank you jerry rohini will go to you
thanks i don't think i have much to add
the one thing the one last point i'd
probably add and maybe this goes back to
the discussion of where did the
inequality discussion go in development
is that we are also hoping to
in some in a lot of ways not silo
development i mean development was a
very odd product as a discipline was a
very odd product it was defined by
in the end of colonialism and
most fields and economics are not
defined by country they're defined by
for instance they're thinking about
labor economics they're thinking about
issues in public economics
and today the the field of development
in some ways is uh perhaps killed by its
own success in that it you know if
you're talking about issues of say
affirmative action inequality this
conversation should be happening across
people thinking about them in the us in
malaysia in india and yet sometimes that
gets very siloed
you know issues of inequality need to be
dealt by thinking about tax systems and
public finance but that's
if you look at the public finance
literature that's usually a very u.s
focused literature in in economics so i
think one thing that
i would love to see come out over the
next few years
as we've brought in these conversations
is really to say that when we ask these
questions we we shouldn't really think
about it os development because it's
talking about nigeria and it's not
development because it's talking about
the us or uk but rather think about what
the question is and i hope that this
conference gets us started on that
thanks raheeny great points so that
concludes this opening session of the
symposium and again this is just the
beginning of a virtual symposium devoted
to race ethnicity gender and economic
justice around the world hosted by
yale's economic growth center and
inclusion economics yale it will
continue on friday october 29th and
friday november 5th with researchers
presenting on the cost of discrimination
based on race ethnicity and gender and
paths to economic justice you can see
information on registration here in zoom
if you're joining us live we really
appreciate all of you in the audience
for taking the time to tune in thanks
for your great questions i look forward
to continuing the conversation during
the symposium and thanks again to our
panelists
you